قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
ان الدوله الفلسطينيه يجب ان تكون جزءا من
اي جهود تكامل او تطبيع بين اسرائيل
وجيرانها في الشرق الاوسط مؤكدا انه لا
يزال هناك اهتمام واضح بمواصله تطبيع
العلاقات بين اسرائيل ودول اخرى بالمنطقه
رغم ما وصفها بالاعمال العدائيه المستمره
واكد بلينكن خلال جولته الاخيره ان
التطبيع مع اسرائيل ليس بديلا عن السلام
ولا يمكن ان يتم على حساب الافق السياسي
للفل ينيين مشددا على ان ذلك كان واضحا
خلال محادثاته في دول المنطقه بما فيها
السعوديه فيما يتعلق بمساله التطبيع
وبالرغم من استمرار الاعمال العدائيه هناك
رغبه مؤكده في مواصله تطبيع العلاقات بين
اسرائيل وعدد من الدول في المنطقه هناك
دول طبعت واخرى ترغب في التطبيع لكن هذا
لا يمكن ان يكون بديلا او على حساب افق
سياسي فلسطينيين ودوله فلسطينيه بل على
النقيض من ذلك تماما فاي سلام او دمج
لاسرائيل بالمنطقه يجب ان يكون جزءا من
جهود التطبيع وقد اوضحت ذلك في لقاءاتي
خلال الجوله بما فيها
السعوديه